so I'm talking to someone who needs no
introduction and so I Drive straight
straight in this is 175 years since the
Economist was set up it's a special time
for us it's a birthday year and it's
also a birthday year in a way for you
because it's twenty-one years since new
laborers swept to power in a landslide
and I want to give a few highlights of
the time that that were the things that
happened in that 21 years so in 1998
your friend and advisor Peter Mandelson
said he was intensely relaxed about
people getting filthy rich as long as
they pay their taxes and then in 2003
the Iraq war and then in 2004 ten-year
member states of the European Union and
only Britain Sweden and Ireland opened
their labor markets immediately there
were predictions at 5,000 to 13,000
people would come in and actually at the
end it was 20 times that many it seems
to me and I've given a whistle-stop tour
of some of the reasons that we are where
we are today and your fingerprints and
our fingerprints are all over it we
cheered every one of those things we
thought it was a great way to run an
economy that you have bankers earned a
lot and take 40% we agreed at the Iraq
war we agreed that freedom of movement
of labour is a great idea and yes here
we are we've had the financial crisis we
have the polarization we have the anger
that people feel about a rich elite that
has taken off and we have anger about
immigration we have breaks it we have
populace doing well everywhere were we
wrong do i honest about it
[Applause]
by the way Helen we didn't only do those
things we've just had a guy on speaking
about LGBT rights we did a little bit on
that I think and a minimum wage and he
was Irish
right the Irish peace agreements - but I
agree okay we've got a big challenge
with liberalism question is is
liberalism dead no it's not how does it
regain its position in in in politics
not just here but around the Western
world right now and I think there are
three things that are really important
the first is I don't think we will get
our position back unless we deal with
the underlying grievances that have
driven people to this situation
now you mentioned immigration that's one
issue for sure
if you don't deal with immigration today
in European politics you're gonna get
nowhere but there's a way of dealing
with the immigration question with rules
and controls that doesn't lead you to an
anti-immigrant position based on
prejudices is that just appearances is
that giving people the appearance that
we heard they're in control when they
aren't really no I think the Regeneron
controls that we can make and indeed
both in freedom of movement and in
immigration outside of Europe but let's
be clear over all immigrations been a
positive thing for our societies but we
got to deal with people's grievances and
anxieties do you think did we ignore
them too much where they just not listen
to well I think by the way last election
I thought was solely around immigration
from the Conservative Party and we had a
whole set of proposals to deal with it
but no it's a tough issue because your
people are on the move and there are
flows of migration happening in the
world but people worry and they're
anxious that some people who come into
our countries don't buy properly by our
values there are issues to do with
integration and we've got to address
those questions I mean one of the things
you guys came under attack for was
always having Steve ban and as one of
your your guests I think in in America
my view is you've got to engage with the
people who disagree with you and you've
got to be prepared to go out and argue
your case and listen to them and build
bridges to them can I ask the audience
who here thinks that we made a mistake
and inviting but Steve Fallon I know
that people who really hated the idea
for he didn't come stick your hand up if
you think we made a mistake okay they
will stayed away they think
Tony so building bridges is one thing
listening for those who disagree second
thing we've got to switch then the
conversation we've got to develop a new
policy agenda that allows us to become
again the change makers are not the
managers of the status quo one of the
most depressing things about British
politics right now is the absence of the
huge debate around the impact of the new
technological revolution what it means
what's going to happen its displacement
effects its potential benefits we have
to switch the conversation and say these
are the challenges of the future so you
have to deal with the issues that people
are worried about you have to develop a
new policy agenda your editor by the way
wrote a brilliant essay mani it's worth
reading and she suggests some of the
policies that you might adopt it give us
a couple of headline policies just you
know one sentence what are we talking
about biggest thing is tech yeah in my
view second housing yep taxing land
values rather than type of taxation
system we have at the moment
infrastructure education okay and then
the third thing is we've got to recover
a bit of confidence about our own
beliefs I mean I was as you know last
night in a conference in the Ukraine
right you go and tell those people that
liberal values don't matter
they've lost ten thousand people in a in
a war because they want to be part of
the European Union and part of NATO so I
actually interviewed last night they're
present at of Estonia and when she was
asked what does the European Union
done for you she said well I can tell
you when we left the Soviet Union our
average income was $30 a month is now
1300 euros so one of the other things
which is why I'm so passionately opposed
to brexit is because when you actually
look at at Europe and NATO and some of
the institutions that liberalism has
created these have actually brought
immense progress and prosperity
so whatever the challenges don't let's
lose confidence in our basic way of life
if you go and talk to people who don't
have an independent media who don't have
the rule of law who don't have a
democracy you'll find they care about
the
she's and don't take them for granted
sometimes in the way we do and yes we do
take them for granted and in some ways
when you've lived somewhere yeah I'm
fine thanks I'm afraid you put something
in it after that introduction I'll get
you one handed up yeah and so here we
are and we aren't confident and we have
a couple of challenges not just here in
Britain but in plenty of countries that
it's rather hard to see our way forward
from because all the options are
unpalatable there are people who feel
very very strongly large numbers of them
who feel very strongly that anything
that we could do in the way of break is
it is a bad idea
there's people who don't want to go
ahead there's people who only want hard
breaks it there's going to be people who
are angry and we're not the only place
that it feels like this how do we find
some if not consensus because consensus
is boring there's never going to be
consensus in a democracy how do we find
a polite conversation that gives us some
ideas moving forward well I think Briggs
is a classic example of what I mean I
don't think I personally as you know in
this will surprise no one this one of
these issues that does divide people
very deeply I am passionately opposed to
breaks it I think it is a fundamental
mistake for this country in its future
but I don't think that you can change
brexit unless you deal with as I say
some of the issues
let's hear underlie it and so people who
feel excluded from the benefits of
globalization communities left behind
and this immigration issue they've all
got to be dealt with but I think you can
deal with them without us leaving in the
21st century the largest political union
biggest commercial market right now a
path to this though this is what worries
me the time is ticking away there's a
hard deadline and even the most basic
decisions haven't been it's definitely a
path to it I mean the path to it I think
is is I think it's very difficult to get
any proposition through Parliament and
and that is because there's a
fundamental dilemma which the
negotiation has never resolved which is
you either stay close to Europe in order
to minimize economic damage in which
case Europe will insist you abide by its
rules or you break from Europe
completely and get out of the single
market out of the customs union in which
case there will be real economic damage
and that
has never been resolved so I think the
government will find it hard to get
their proposition through and I
personally believe that there isn't
paralysis in Parliament the best
response is to put it back to the people
and say look we've a tune of half years
experience of this negotiation we now
know all the different options do you
want to proceed or do you want to stay
and isn't this because of the failure of
Parliament and we're in a representative
democracy we elect these people to come
to these decisions for us and among the
people who have failed are the Labour
Party is the Labour Party irredeemable
should there be a new party should the
be a centrist party should we give up
yeah come on tell us what you really
think well I think I've already said and
I repeat I'm obviously worried about the
Labour Party I don't agree with its
present direction and I actually do
believe that the Labour Party said to
the British people now look the
government's had two years to get this
right it hasn't got it right we can't
support the deal that they're offering
we think you should make the final call
on this I personally think they would be
twenty points out in the opinion poll
not the level pegging but I may be
completely wrong I mean the fear I have
is that we'll be near to 50/50 again
what the result would be near to 50/50
again this is this is just the first
possible thing that could happen I know
but the fact is the divisions
I'm afraid are there now the only way
out of it I can think of is to
rehabilitate the politics of building
bridges which is why and I think this is
exactly true in the United States as
well you know they've got a choice
between you just try and stack up your
supporters and beat the Trump supporters
or you can ask yourself the question why
did some people not all of whom are
chanting locker up at rallies vote for
Donald Trump and the politics of
building bridges is out of fashion at
the moment but I think it should come
back into fashion because it's in the
end the only way you can resolve what
are otherwise big economic and also
cultural issues I mean I think
it's it's very easy for people on the
liberal side of politics to place
emphasis on the economic challenges of
globalization
you know stagnant incomes people left
behind without opportunity but ignore
the cultural so what sort of cultural
things what what are we talking about
are we talking about Muslim immigration
here let's put you know let's ask it in
the most blunt possible way yes I think
that's an anxiety for people unless
they're sure that those who are coming
into our countries share the values of
prepared to abide by those values I
think there's nothing unreasonable in
saying that but I also think it's it's
about a feeling that the modern world is
changing very fast around people and
they've lost control over it now I don't
think the answer to that is to go back
to old-style left solutions of the past
which has give the state more power but
I do think we're gonna have to help
prepare people for what is going to be
enormous change to come I mean I look
I'm not a you're about to talk to some
tech experts and I'm as my children
always say to me please don't talk in
public about tech because just embarrass
yourself it's a very apparent you don't
know what you're talking about but I
mean I think this this is going to
transform every single aspect of our
lives but I think the transformation we
always look at is the negative side of
it you know it will displace jobs and so
on it can also liberate enormous
protective potential you know could
change our education system our health
care system and beneficially so you know
I think if there was one single thing
that is a word the liberal side that
politics should do it should be
mastering this technological revolution
in all its different aspects and weaving
it into a narrative that expresses some
optimism about the future I want to give
you a another little Whistlestop bit of
you know your time and power but a nicer
one no you'll like this one
so I started at the Economist in 2005
and I was the education correspondent
and lovely things I wrote about for my
first few years working at the Economist
SureStart more money for schools
teachers having time to do their admin
and so on I miss those days terribly and
early in the time that I started a man
called David Cameron who was the shadow
of Education a spokesperson at the time
for the Conservatives came in
it was slightly before he looked like
the front-runner for becoming the next
leader of the Conservative Party and I
remember him saying you know I am the
heir to Blair and I remember him saying
that we will share the proceeds of
growth it doesn't that sound lovely now
sharing the proceeds of growth now we're
cutting and we're trying to work out
where to cut and I wonder how we can get
that positive narrative again and how we
can persuade people that there is space
to do new things when as far as the eye
can see we're going to be cutting the
populations are aging there's more to do
with less people are getting sicker etc
etc we turned into a negative sum game
and we used to be in a positive sum game
yeah but I think this is absolutely
right and you're correct in identifying
this challenge but the point is this
this is why you need to look at this not
not from a sort of ideological
perspective right or left but realize
that what's happening is society's
changing because the world around it is
changing very fast and that's why I say
that the task of people if you like in
the center is to make sense of that
where is the center now I see no Center
I just see people racing off as fast as
they can to the two directions and
leaving nobody talking to anyone and
despoil the ground it's still there it's
just not particularly represented in our
politics right now but you know you can
take macro in France and that's an
example of a centrist politician winning
but you said that here our political
system is going to basically make that
sort of thing impossible and I'm not
sure it's impossible but it's obviously
very difficult because the party system
is pretty pile driven into the political
landscape here but I think there's
plenty of people who if they're offered
if you like a an agenda that is socially
liberal that tries to find new ways of
bringing communities together and
producing greater opportunity for those
that don't understands that you need a
growing economy with a thriving
enterprise sector alongside it I think
there's plenty of people who believe in
those ideas I think the problem is when
when we look for people to blame you
know whether it's business on the left
or immigrants on the right rather than
understanding this is a world of change
and we've got to master it but we can I
mean it's not you know if you if you
take a big step back and look at the
broad sweep of humanity's history you
know we have made progress and one of
the things there's a
two great books one by Keuchel rustling
another by a guy called Pinker which are
worth reading which basically just give
you the the antidote to continual
pessimism about the world because they
point out quite rightly there's been
more people lifted out of poverty than
ever before in human history I mean I do
a lot of work in Africa all the decimal
killer diseases are coming down the
middle class is set to double even in
our own societies you know when I think
of the world that our kids are growing
up in and the world my father grew up in
there's a foster child and a poor part
of Glasgow in the nineteen thirties I
mean we still made progress so what
we've got to do is reignite the politics
of optimism I do want to ask you one
more brings a related question and maybe
it's on this sort of politics of
optimism thing what can the EU do what
should it do and what can it do to try
to help us I mean maybe they maybe
they've given up on Britain but maybe
they haven't maybe there's something
they could do to help break this impasse
yeah I think there is I think if you hit
paralysis in the British Parliament
might be has that they should make us an
offer and they should deal with our
issues on immigration and freedom of
movement but it's by the way the
European issues I mean
immigration is not just a British issue
it's all over Europe right now as you
can see if you look at Italian politics
Swedish politics any time mostly talking
about immigrants from the rest of the EU
mostly freedom of movement is pretty
popular it's from outside the EU they're
worried no I think you'll find that
within Europe today even on in relation
to freedom movement within the European
Union they're prepared to make changes
but I think look the most important
thing to understand about Europe is
again the way the world's changing when
I I've got grandchildren now when they
were in their early 30s the row
basically gonna be three giants in the
world China India and America and these
countries are going to be more dominant
and bigger their economies are going to
be several times the size of any other
economies and countries in the world and
then you've got some tall countries
which will be Indonesia Brazil Russia
and so on many of us once we're not
minnows but we're medium-sized Germany
Italy France UK the only way we are
going to exercise influence and weight
in the modern world is if we're together
and that's the reason for the European
Union today in my father's generation
the logic was peace and we produce peace
but the logic today is power so tell me
what the offer they make should be what
on freedom of movement what else do they
need to say to make to break this
impasse I think you need to recognize
that when there's a sudden influx of
people into an area it can be a big
problem
I think you need to recognize the people
who are in the host community think you
shouldn't just come in and immediately
start claiming benefits and so on I
think there is a real case three made as
indeed there's a new European directive
on this coming up which is to stop the
undercutting of wages and then I think
Europe should as it's now proposing
tighten its external borders because
there's a big problem and by the way
we're going to have a huge problem in
time to come from North Africa where
you've got exploding populations poor
countries and radicalization so there
are masses of things that we can do my
point is very simple none of the
problems that Britain has and the
challenges it faces are going to be
easier to resolve out of Europe they're
actually going to be easier to resolve
in Europe and the thing that pains me is
when you know you have a young
working-class person in the north of
England thinks that they're more likely
to get a job if we stop some polish guy
coming and working in a bar in London it
isn't true
so the actual answered his problems is
to educate him properly but that's of
course it within the control of the
British government that's not something
that Britain ever had to rely on the EU
to do no of course but that's why the
the agenda be part of the trouble with
breaks it is not just its destructive
impact but it's distractive impact I
mean the truth is the things the
government should be concentrating upon
today are around digitalization
education infrastructure and it's very
hard to do that now look I'm you know
I'm sympathetic actually to Prime
Minister one since I've done the job and
a difficult two days but I think if we
carry on down this path we won't resolve
any of the problems we think we resolve
and that's the problem with populism is
that it rides the anger it doesn't
actually provide the answer so what do
you think there are some young people in
this room younger than we often have at
Economist conferences those young people
should they join a political party and
if so which one where is their voice
best hurt
what else should they do what can they
do to help to create this new center
because people like this these people
are going to be the people because it's
the mistakes that we are making and have
made definitely get active yes I think
you can join political parties I'm not
going to tell you which one you can join
but you can join political parties but
you can get engaged in campaigns I mean
everything doesn't happen through
political parties today but the other
thing I think is to realize one of the
good things about democracy today is
people aren't differential ok so that's
good you know that I remember watching
an interview with climatically when he
was Prime Minister and the interviewer
said to him at the end of the interview
said mr. Attlee is there anything else
you would like to add this wouldn't
happen nowadays ok this is not the way
people approach things and that's good
no deference
Bango is my last question by the way you
believe me yeah but if you don't have
deference and you want to treat your
politicians rightly as much more
fallible I think there's also an
obligation to understand how difficult
and tough the business of politics is
and one of the things that I think is
you know frustrating particularly in an
area of social media which itself as a
revolutionary phenomenon is that
politics if you're not careful becomes
an exchange of abuse and an exchange of
slogans rather than a serious argument I
mean you were so right on social media
and you know just talking we're saying
so much more unpleasant things than we
would have 5 or 10 years ago how do you
wrote back when you've gone look this is
not a very politically correct thing to
say but the problem with the social
media it is it is the sort of in a sense
the platform for the loud-mouthed to be
absolutely honest about it because what
happens is you know people just spew
forth their opinions but I think
underneath all of that there is still a
longing in a desire for rational
argument and for taking issues and
looking at them in a proper way and you
know one of the things you learn about
politics when you actually get into
government so the difference is when
you're in opposition you know it is all
about great speeches and resolutions and
blah when you can't get into government
you suddenly realize it's a tough
business and it involves tough choices
and when you decide you divide so it's
hard there needs to be a far greater
honest dialogue today between political
leaders and people and you ask what
should young people do get involved in
that dialogue but do it in a way that
isn't just so the finger jabbing saying
to the politicians why aren't you doing
this and why you're doing that and why
don't you then the next thing but also
engaging and understanding the
complexity the difficulty the choices
the priorities because that's why cause
it takes a yeah that's what politics is
about but in all of this
never forget that we have something
really precious which is we do elect our
own government so you know we've got
Hong Kong's hearing this getting
streamed that's right yeah well so we
have a hard stop at the end of this
because we are going to get be going to
hearted to and colleagues abroad but I
want to ask and I would like to take a
question from a young person who's in
the room is there anyone who wants to
ask mister player a short quick question
and I will preferentially pick somebody
who doesn't look as old as me come on
yes I have a hand here you need you need
to take the mic no one else put their
hand up so it's you it's a young
person's mic you see right just speak
so why does the devil have all the best
tunes on brakes it right
we have counting down one minute 38
thank you I'm not sure they do by the
way
I mean I think people actually um
they've done a really good job arguing
the opposite case but look I tell you
what I learn in politics and that is
that if it's a fight between the
populism of the left and the populism of
the right the right will win okay and
that's why the only way you're going to
defeat it is to put a rational politics
in its place and have a different type
of dialogue with people switch the
conversation to a different set of
challenges and be proud of the fact that
you're prepared to talk to people who
disagree because in the end if you end
up with a situation where you've just
got Jeremy Corbyn and his guys on one
side Boris Johnson and their people on
the other side personally I will find
that a deeply depressing scenario for
for the country but I just tell you I
think there is still a large number of
people in the country who would opt for
a politics that says I'm not going to
get engaged in the name-calling of
either of those two but I am going to
develop an agenda that addresses the
future and does so in a way that does
genuinely try to provide answers to our
problems rather than simply taking a
constituency of people and making them
really angry about someone else where's
the leadership well that's a nice he
looks older than me so it wasn't a young
person saying it sadly I'm going to say
thank you very much you are both a very
good sport and you gave me as good as I
gave you so thank you very much for that
thank you
[Music]
you
[Applause]
you